ok allez c'est parti on démarre à qui on
va démarrer avec gilbert dit je pense
pas qu'il est prêt allez c'est parti
attention et oui ni non il me dit allez
c'est parti
you mon gars comment ça va tu vas bien
très bien merci
tu sais que je parle anglais je savais
pas toujours speak english
moi je parle très bien anglais très bien
anglais fait mon anglais os que tu me
suis sur instagram
pas du tout je vais faire je promis je
vais le faire suis moi sur un style
sommes d'accord avec grand plaisir mon
ami à j'adore ta coupe de cheveux tard
fais tes lèvres
non non bien bas djama on va lui mettre
ça à pas jamais merci il va bien on s'en
sert d joignez s'y rapportent toi boris
approche toi comment on trouve qu'elle
by chaque année c'est parti tu aurais
bien très bien
tu veux qu'on les émissions secret story
plus aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui et prépara prime brokerage
story c'est ce à quoi il y aura un prime
sur les 20 ans du loft
on nettoie tous ça fait déjà deux tours
vingt ans déjà peut-on déjà incroyable
qu'en coupe de cheveux j'ai un très bon
coiffeur cette france qui ce soir hier
qui vous raconter ce n'est pas ce rail à
ces poissons rien et ils trichent il est
trop ce goût là enfin je ne perds jamais
l'intuition menaçant mais des factures à
pile quand vous jouez sur ma pizza
rappelez-vous parvenir tout ce qu'on dit
poser des questions alors c'est un peu
de fond teint toujours toujours c'est
bien moi aussi j'en ai mis ça soit pas
franchement je sais que tu es chaud il
est voué au sud où il a perdu il a perdu
il a perdu ibra kane a dit à juste en
dessous ouais j'avais perdu je crois
vous avez perdu allez hop je vous ai
répondu henri allez hop
non mais moi
amenez moi tu peux le faire qui veut le
faire qu'elle est de nouveau ni indiquer
le sens des partis auxquels il est nommé
10 c'est parti fanny alors le change on
comptera charge
vas-y tu peux commencer tu peux
commencer ni oui ni non du coup
alessandri gosses et pluton cruche mon
crâne c'est pas ton cross et puis arrête
de mentir arrête on le sait tous
alexandre bigot mais bien sûr que c'est
pas vrai nom wolof
ah ah
[Musique]
[Rires]
n'allez pas des guirlandes qui est
qu'ils aient envie de le faire vous
sainte-catherine attention c'est parti
c'est parti la sortir un livre elle a
perdu pourquoi ça va delphine quelque
chose comme ça c'est super oui bien sûr
aux incroyables
du coup tu m'as l'air super lot must
bien sûr bien sûr tu parle anglais tout
à l'heure tu as cru que j'étais un
anglais atroce tu vas me ramener une
tasse de café bientôt n'ont pas encore
les électeurs n'ont pas
[Musique]
moi je propose qu'on en fasse un petit
dernier un petit dernier à san luis le 6
mai et enfin à 100 cd ou les [ __ ]
pour les assauts du coup il aima pour
l'essence et des lettres il collabore du
top c'est parti
alors on y va on y va attention je ne
choisirais je vais te choisir un bon bah
y voilà c'est pas la table mais l'art
est là tu as trop de trucs sur la tête
là je vous écoute franchement la façon
dont et ses protégés ouais c'est honteux
franchement c'est honteux une ex deux
paires de lunettes solaires de trois
paires de lunettes quand vous avez pris
trop et là même que vous ne voyez pas
qui bouge avec la tête mais ça va perdre
en fait ça pourquoi tu fais ça pour me
protéger mais c'est toi que j'ai croisés
tout à l'heure on s'est croisé dans les
loges je me souviens pas nous tu te
souviens pas de moi absolument pas
absolument pas t'es sûrement pas ah
ouais alors questions pour un champion
est ce que tu as déjà trompé sa femme
jamais jamais bien est ce que tu as déjà
trompé civile cyril papa qui a trompé
mon gmail et son petit fils mais je le
ferai si les jamais parti dans une autre
émission que jamais ok d'accord
franchement tu as un bon s'asseoir à
atteindre et ça c'est un bon teint très
bons et les très beaux arts dont 200
civils sont cédés pour les restos du
coeur c'est important ça c'est important
ça me touche à coeur le rappeur aussi
obtenir que tu nommes j'ai adoré le
spectacle parce que ce que je peux en
faire partie
chanter s'enchaîner pour les restos du
coeur les chemins 16 décembre et joker
que j'adore